هنا على هذه التله كانت مستوطنه حومش التي
اخليت عام 2005 بحكم قضائي وضمن قانون فك
الارتباط تطل جاثمه على بلده برقه
الفلسطينيه وتقطع الطريق بين نابلس وجنين
وطولكرم بل انها اقيمت على اراضي اهالي
البلده الفلسطينيين الذين سعوا الاسترداد
ارضهم بعد اخلاء المستوطنه دون جدوى وضع
جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي يده عليها
متدرعا بدواع امنيه وعسكريه
لكن ومنذ بضع سنوات ضغطت الجماعات
الاستيطانيه واليمين المتطرف نحو العوده
الى حومش وتحقق ذلك بتمرير الكنيست مشروعه
الغاء قانون فك الارتباط في اذار مارس
الماضي الذي يمهد لعوده الاستيطان الى
اربع مستوطنات شماليه الضفه الغربيه
اخليت منذ نحو عقدين
لينزل الخبر كالصاعقه على اهالي بلده برقه
فوجود مستوطنه يجلب معه عنف المستوطنين
ومضايقاتهم واغلاقا للطرقات وتعطيلا
للحياه اليوميه كل حياه البلده وسكان
البلده سيتاثر حتى بحياته الاجتماعيه حتى
بالزواج وبالوفاه بالتنقل بالتواصل
الاجتماعي ستتاثر بالكامل لانها هي
اعتداءاتهم ستبقى متواصله 18 عاما عاشها
اهالي برقه على امل استرداد اراضيهم منذ
ان اخلت اسرائيل مستوطنه حومش عام 2005 لم
تسلم اسرائيل الارض حينها رغم الحكم
القضائي واليوم تعود حومش مشروعا
استيطانيا جديدا يزيد من تقطيع اوصال
الضفه الغربيه ويقوض حلم الفلسطينيين
بدولتهم المنشوده تضافح الى مسلسل قدم
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المستمر من قبل
الجماعات الاستيطانيه قدم يدفع بتسريع
وتييرته اليمين الديني المتطرف الذي اصبح
شريكا في الحكم باسرائيل لجعل الواقع على
الارض عقبه تنهي مشروع حل الدولتين
اسرائيل تستولي على مساحات كبيره من الارض
في الضفه الغربيه وتتوسع هناك ببناء
المستوطنات والبؤر الاستيطانيه رغم انها
غير شرعيه حسب القانون الدولي وحتى
الاسرائيلي ورغم الضغوط الدوليه تمضي
حكومه نتنياهو واحزاب اليمين المتطرف
المنضويه تحت ائتلافه الحاكم بتسريع وتيره
الاستيطان في الضفه الغربيه والقدس
الشرقيه واطفاء الشرعيه على البؤر
الاستيطانيه غير عابئه بما يتبع ذلك من
عناصر التوتر احمد هزيم الجزيره من بلده
برقه في الضفه الغربيه